CNBC gives us an update on Biden's
student loan forgiveness so we know that
these the loan forgiveness was passed
and uh well sorry it was not passed
makes it sound like it was legislation
it wasn't it was decreed
and uh illegally unconstitutionally
and whatever happened with that you know
are are there a lot of
people college graduates that had
student loans and they've been able to
pay them off or they've been able to pay
into that principle and and you know and
have some Financial stability well let's
find out
recipients of President Biden's student
debt forgiveness plan could see their
monthly payments drop up to 300 a month
in the coming weeks but get this 73 say
they actually plan to spend that extra
cash on travel and dining out and
joining us now is the NBC Tech check
co-anchor Deirdre Bosa so Deirdre why
are people more inclined to spend the
money they're saving on non-essentials
instead of paying off their bills I
think we may know the answer
well that that could be according to one
survey but you know it could be easy as
well for some people to enjoy traveling
and eating out rather than worrying
about the future One Financial coach
tell cnbc.com that you should not use
the loan forgiveness only for long-term
goals your short short-term self may get
frustrated and give up on planning ahead
altogether so instead they say make sure
your regular bills are paid check in on
your goals and try to achieve a balance
that also lets you invest in your future
self
oh okay good yeah well you because yeah
you don't want to plan for the future
too much and that might make you
frustrated and so you really just want
to make sure you can enjoy the moment
and have good mental health and yeah
have a nice night out on town
that's good Financial advice
never mind the fact that you're you're
you're stealing that money from American
taxpayers so that you can just go and
and uh have a nice dinner or go on a
vacation
like the CNBC is reporting it like oh
it's is that that's an interesting fun
little tidbit
so we are taking money from hard-working
blue-collar Americans who didn't go to
college made different choices made
better choices actually uh many of them
said I can't afford college so I'm not
going to go and try to pay I'm not going
to I'm not going to take out a loan I
can't afford
um as opposed to the college graduates
who went ahead and did that
and now we're taking money from them it
was bad enough we're taking money from
them to pay off the financial
obligations you're paying off someone
else's financial obligation you're
paying for you know a commitment that
someone else made but then we find out
not surprisingly that you're not even
paying off that commitment or that
obligation because they're just going
off and wasting the money elsewhere
it's uh I mean it's a it is actually an
absolute moral outrage
taking money from
you know working-class people
so that upper class College grads can go
on vacation I cannot think of it's hard
to think of something more outrageous
than that
and you know again not not a this is a
feature not a bug
of course the buy Administration news is
going to happen they're fine with it
and it's totally predictable too because
this is all this all feeds into this
entitlement mentality
now the people that were calling for
student loan forgiveness in the first
place all of them entitled brats
every single person calling for loan
forgiveness
saying that the loan that I took out the
obligation that I have the commitment
that I made should be paid for by
someone else because I don't give a damn
about those other people
I'll take food out of their mouths I'll
take food out of their children I'll
take food off of their off of their
children's plate
for for me because the commitment that I
made but I don't feel like living up to
so every single person calling for that
all of them every single one entitled
spoiled brats
is it a big surprise then that you give
them the money and they just go waste it
that's what entitled spoiled brats do
and you know something they're gonna go
waste the money and they're still going
to have the student loan which they have
not paid down at all and now they're
going to go back to Biden and say well
we need more forgiveness this isn't fair
you know I took the money I went to
Cancun and I but I still have the
student loan forgiveness but I still
have the student loan I'm I'm crushed by
the burden of this debt feels sorry for
me
and then Biden will just give them more
money
that's the way these works and I'll do
it for us for this portion of the show
as we move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]